now the Diabolical thing about the flu
virus is that just like the Diabolical
thing about the cold virus you start
shedding virus that is you are
contagious about 24 hours prior to the
onset of first symptoms for you so that
means that you can be a flu viral Vector
even when you aren't having symptoms
that's just the unfortunate aspect of
these viruses they're very clever they
don't have brains but these viruses have
adapted to propagate from host to host
to host they have a drive to continue to
stay alive and to infect more host so
even though they don't have a brain they
have a sort of uh let's call it viral
intelligence and as I've said several
times now if you are still exhibiting
symptoms of the colder flu you are
contagious however with respect to the
flu you are most contagious during the
three days when you feel the absolute
worst when your fever is at its worst
when you are coughing and sneezing
headache all of that when that is at its
peak that is when you are most
contagious